loop's can be combined together with
each other and with functions can make
codes both readable and versatile in
this case we'll show a nested for loop a
nested for loop is a loop inside another
loop when we hit the first for statement
we define the value I x is equal to the
first value of the array in the loop
declaration in this case the array is an
array of doubles and the value of the
first element of the rate is one when we
hit the second for statement we define a
second loop variable in this case the
variable is iy iy will be set equal to
the first value of the rate in this
group's declaration in this case the
array is an array of cells I why is
there for self the first time through
the loop the cell has the array of
characters lego now the code calls for a
function that takes two variables and
does something our function juggles one
Lego brick note that in this case the
function is not returning any values
when it's done when we hit the first end
statement we repeat the innermost poorly
the value of IX has not changed only the
value of I why is change in this case
the second value in our array is a cell
with the word Apple again the loop
passes the values over to the function
and the function juggles one
[Music]
when the end is hit this time there are
no more values in the iy array that lab
proceeds to the next line of code which
is another end statement this time for
the outermost need now we increment the
value in IX to the second element of the
array the value 3 the next line of code
is a declaration for the inner for loop
which we will now run again the fact
that we ran this loop before has no
influence on how the loop will run now
the first time you go through the loop I
will still become a cell with the word
Lego blue passes its values to function
the function juggles three-legged the
second time the loop runs the function
juggles three apples now we hit our end
statement and the code updates the I x
value there is only one more element in
there right so this is the last time we
will execute the outermost loop this
time the value is set to 80 for IX will
have the value of 84 + iy will have the
value Lego as always not a bad idea to
have your function check to make sure
the values are reasonable
[Music]